my head's a britain's intelligence
agencies as you've just been hearing
have warned leaving the EU would pose a
security risk writing in The Sunday
Times the former leaders of mi5 and mi6
a vote for brexit could undermine what
they describe as our ability to protect
ourselves from terrorists while the
shadow Defense Secretary emily Thornbury
is with me now in a very good morning to
you your reaction to that do you go
along with these I mean esteemed former
heads of our two main intelligence
agencies I think that we should take
very seriously what people who have no
political ax to grind have to say on
this and they are experts on it and so
yes I think this is I think the one of
the major reasons for remaining in the
European Union is in order to ensure
that we safeguard our security I think
our ability to be able to exchange
information and to be able to work with
allies is very important indeed okay so
that endorsed now let's stay with the
issue of security and Sadiq Khan of
course elected as the new mayor of
London I mean do you believe as some of
the conservative scientists said that
London is a less safe City as a result I
think then Michael Fallon particularly
my my opposite number has made the most
outrageous claims about about Sadiq Khan
and I think that he should take them
back I think it's an insult and I'm very
angry about it I'm very angry about the
way in which they ran this campaign I
think they try to divide London and
frankly London came back with a
resounding answer which is we are a
multiracial multicultural city and we're
proud of it we like it that way we're
not going to have anybody divide us
so dog-whistle the the Donald Trump
PlayBook it's been - I think that's
absolutely right I think there's
actually what it was and I think they
shouldn't be forgiven I think they
should apologize and I think we should
never see anything like that again and
you know I think it's fantastic to see
him as Sadiq elect he was such an a
resounding victory on Thursday and also
look at Bristol I mean Bristol where we
have an afro-caribbean man now who
doubled his vote from four years ago
it's it's amazing it's such good news
well I mean let's talk about Bristol at
under because you know Jeremy Corbyn
leader of course went to Bristol to
celebrate that event as Sadiq Khan was
being sworn in in London do you think
there's a bit of a rift between the two
well what can you do you know go and win
two mayoral teasin the way that we did
on the same night you can't be in two
places at once
and so he went down to Bristol because I
think actually there's not been a lot of
attention paid to Bristol but it is an
extraordinary result in Bristol to have
doubled the number of votes in four
years I mean it is really showing a
difference people keep saying that
labour can't win in the southeast war
hey you know we have had a fantastic
result in Bristol a fantastic result in
London we've had great results in Exeter
up Hampton a major conurbations yeah
okay but on the issue of Sadiq Khan he
hasn't taken long to distance himself
has he from Jeremy Corbyn Corbin
Easter's as they called her tweeting
this morning saying well we supported
him throughout his campaign and now he
says all this about big tents we've got
to be a centrist party we've got to
appeal to people who voted conservative
we've got to tell people who we want to
come back to vote for us that the
economy is safe in our hands well who
would disagree with that of course we've
got to be a big tent and of course we've
got to appeal to everybody you think
generally got to do ever of course
that's how Jeremy wouldn't disagree with
that you know we need to make sure that
we that we stop talking amongst
ourselves about ourselves and gazing at
our navels and we need to be able to get
out there and fight some elections and
speak to people about issues that matter
you know Sadiq was absolutely right to
talk about housing there guess what
jeremy corbyn's last question at prime
minister's questions was about housing
did David Cameron answer it no David
Cameron wanted to talk about
Islamophobia you know we had the answers
on issues that people were interested in
that's why we have done as well as we
have done in many of the places that we
have so you're saying Jeremy Corbyn runs
this this big tent is one nation that he
can appeal and you must know that the
statistics that you're faced with after
the overall election results
particularly in Scotland at labour to
win the next general election has to
achieve a 13 percent swing in England
that's not likely to happen
I mean it's I'm not saying that it's not
going to be hard but you know let's also
put let's also put on the table the
other facts so you know so so we did 4%
better than we did in the general
election so we are going in the right
direction of course Scotland is a big
issue no one's going to pretend that we
don't have big problems in Scotland but
I'll tell you where we have got to in
Scotland now if the SNP have got
devolved all the powers that they need
they
now the establishment in Scotland if
things go wrong in Scotland it is their
fault there are no more excuses you know
falling results in their schools need
the people need to point the finger at
the Scots Nats and I think there will
come a time when we need to be able to
build our fight back you know there was
a time wasn't there when Boris Johnson
won the second mayoral tea in London
people saying all Labour's never gonna
win this again and so on well we did and
we show that we can you can fight back
we have we have ups and downs and in
London and in London we're currently on
an up but in in Scotland we've clearly
got a long way to go how eagerly are
Labour going to fight for Britain to
remain within the European Union we're
reading today that Jeremy Corbyn who we
were expecting to rail in Foursquare now
behind the campaign he's taking a ten
day holiday - what sir--they the end of
the campaign before the vote well I
think it's been pretty full on for
Jeremy hasn't it since he was elected as
leader I do think that when Parliament's
not sitting he should be allowed to have
a few days off we are will we will be
campaigning full-out to stay in Europe
you know labour is a United Party on
this issue and we will be speaking with
one voice he is a team effort and for
Jeremy to have a few days off I don't
think is something that anyone should
regret for one of the most important
decisions facing the entirety of the
United and he's going to be campaigning
on me on the issue and he's going to be
going up and down the country as he has
been throughout these local council
elections you know he will be doing it
and so will I and so all the rest of the
party it's really important that we stay
in Europe okay just want to ask about we
were discussing Islamophobia earlier
weren't with the accusations of that
what about Ken Livingstone man you know
well it friend of yours isn't a catalyst
and really um you know that whole
anti-semitism ray I was talking to him
as well after the elections on Friday
and he was at it again
do you think he's got a point though he
clearly thinks it's very important to
make that that point about the alleged
link he says between Hitler and Zionism
no I don't know I don't i think that
jewish people have played a really
important role in the development of the
Labour Party they have played a really
important role in left and I think that
we have to make it perfectly clear that
they are central to the Labour Party and
remain central to the Labour Party and I
think that any examples of of
anti-semitism have to be rooted out and
I'm really pleased that Jeremy
hibachi has taken the role that she has
well Sid he can't sing he feels that her
labor did not quickly enough on it did
do you agree with that well I mean I
think you took a couple of days but you
know we've done it and we've set up this
enquiry and we've set it up on to
somebody who's a universally respected
buddy you've still got Ken living ttan
ken livingstone that could be back in
the parties he's suspended as I say was
at it again
do you think historically I mean he says
it's historical fact there will be an
inquiry ken can say what he has to say
to the NEC and a decision will be made
right now ken listen there's also been
and we talked about this before hasn't
he involved in the Trident review or not
or he certainly had a few thoughts about
Trident where are we with Labour's
review about the renewal the replacement
of the Trident I'm doing a defense
review as is Labor Party policy so lame
party policy is that there is to be a
review so when I was given the job I was
given the job of doing a review of all
of Defense that means looking at the
21st century threats to Britain and how
we keep written safe because of all jobs
that politicians have we have to keep
our people safe above everything else as
part of that I'm doing a review into
whether or not we should be in favor of
the renewal of the Trident submarines
that is only a part of it but it is
certainly part of it and I appreciate
that when I come out with my review the
only bit that people are likely to read
will be the bit on Trident yeah well
we've got you know I'm doing jobs and
billions of billions of fans doing an
interim report which is which I'm hoping
to release at the end of May but that's
only an interim and that's get then
going to feed into the national policy
making process of the Labour Party but
you've given some some intriguing I
suppose pointers as to the way you're
thinking you still believe that
technology is developing so fast that
submarines may become more or less
obsolete because they will become easier
to detect I think that we have to as
part of the review look at whether or
not these boats will be out of date by
the time they hit the water in the 2030s
and whether they will still be cutting
edge technology as by the twenty six
days because we want to this will be the
single biggest investment this
government will make in anything and for
heaven's sake we want to make sure that
it is as effective as it possibly can be
so it is right to ask these questions
there are problems you know I think
on the horizon in that you know billions
of pounds are being invested in
anti-submarine technology we need to be
confident that if we do by this new
system that we will still be able to
hide in opaque seas we also have to look
at there is a series of other threats
didn't you say was like trying to patrol
the sky with with Spitfires I mean
you're more that's good
more or less convinced I was saying guys
that was that we have in the defense
industry you talk about platforms so you
talk about you know we'll have this
particular type of ship it won't get out
of date because we can bolt on this and
we can add this I was talking about the
tornados which are actually relatively
elderly planes and they are as l/d as as
they four had Spitfires over the over
the over the shores in the 1980s but the
tornados could be absolutely cutting
edge technology by adding things to it
the question is will the platform will
hiding very large submarines in the sea
still were not on the 26 now I know as
as part of this review you are you got
in confusion about the death corn levels
the defense condition levels you know
got Damian McBride advising of you have
read his book he's very good at prepping
his charges as he says with all the
essential information they should have
so no no doubt you've got your DEFCON
levels us potential a secular state for
defense sorted out so DEFCON one is so
the Daily Mail in fact wrote out a had a
little a little card that I was supposed
to keep in my handbag the point I was
trying to make was that let me just make
this point the point I was trying to
make was some people say that we should
have continual at sea nuclear deterrence
so the so the ship should be so the
submarine should be out at all times
right because if we were to if there was
to be a time of heightened tension and
we were to suddenly have another
submarine go out then that would in turn
spiral out tension point I'm making is
that there are publicly acknowledged and
indeed publicized states of readiness in
in the United States and so and so you
need to know what they are you know what
they equate to what is DEFCON one so
DEFCON one is the is the absolute you
know we are about to go imminence of
nuclear war DEFCON two which the world
has been at the United States have been
at that level twice
you know DEFCON two is it is the stage
below it yes
the finger is not above not fishing on a
mission no I don't know the official
definition of DEFCON one
the DEFCON 2 which is the Americans
second stage of nucleus its armed forces
at six hours ready to deploy and you
know when I was Secretary of State
Jews don't fit in the United States that
I'm sure that it would be important for
me to know all the niceties of this the
important of it but we don't you were a
secular state for defense here and you
had control of our nuclear weapons yes
and and the point that I'm making is
whether or not you should have
submarines continually at sea or not or
whether you can instead release the
submarine if you would launch a
submarine if you need to if the tension
you still don't know all your DEFCON
levels I can't tell you what DEFCON 4 is
ok or 3 well it is important isn't it I
mean would you not except it's very
important if you have to take the nation
to DEFCON level 3 and you don't know
what it is yeah yeah I'm sure that I'm
sure then it's what but but this morning
on a Sunday morning after the elections
I can't tell you off the top of my head
but what I can do is I can tell you that
if that when I am Secretary of State for
Defence you'll know it I will know it
you will certainly know I probably
within about 20 minutes - no cause
Damien McBride's
read these keep I'll keep the Daily Mail
in my handbag at all times
I'm sure you do and I'm sure that's what
I always ought to do this day thank you
very much indeed very good to see you
everything